it is now
my great honor to introduce
the president-elect of the united states
of america
joe biden
a long journey for this country but at
prime time he came to accept the job of
leading
for the next four years alongside the
first woman
ever elected vice president america
has never seen a moment like this before
the people of this nation have spoken
they've delivered us a clear victory
a convincing victory a victory
for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast
from presidential ticket
in the history of the nation he knows as
well as anyone that america
is riven as rarely before hence this
attempt
to reach out for all those of you
who voted for president trump i
understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
the drive-in rally was a reminder no one
needed that he'll take over
responsibility for a pandemic running
wild and systemic problems science
let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
it's not some mysterious force beyond
our control
it's a decision a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate
then we can decide to cooperate
make no mistake the presence of kamala
harris a woman of color in the white
house
is hugely significant for this country
while i may be
the first woman in this office i will
not be the last
because every little girl watching
tonight
sees that this is a country of
possibilities
they were listening all over the country
not least on the streets outside the
white house
[Applause]
celebrations among those yearning an end
to the trump hero
the sitting president had been on the
golf course when his defeat was
confirmed
as he left the thumbs up to his
supporters perhaps a sign
he still feels confident that he has a
chance in the courts
there is little evidence of the fraud
he's alleged
[Music]
when all the celebrations have died down
he'll need all of those skills if he is
to heal america
he's told supporters to keep the faith i
am
so excited and so happy and so
overwhelmed at the same time
i think this is such an amazing moment
we're so relieved
to move on to the decency that this
country deserves
i'm just so proud to be a part of this
moment i think that if anyone's going to
unite
this country and bring us all together
it's the man who you just heard speak
when joe biden's old boss barack obama
offered his congratulations he added a
sobering list of challenges the
president-elect
will face no one should be under any
illusion the difficult times lay ahead
for this country
[Applause]
it was in truth quite a nice change from
the political fireworks we've become
used to
whatever challenges to his legitimacy he
faces joe biden has already begun the
transition for america
he's achieved his ultimate goal and the
hard work
has only just begun greg milam sky news
wilmington in delaware